heute wollen wir darüber sprechen wie
man auf deutsch eine bitte formuliert
wir wollen auch darüber sprechen wann
man das wort bitte benutzt und wann
vielleicht besser nicht los geht's vor
kurzem hat eine nachbarin von mir in
einer nachbarschaft whatsapp gruppe
diesen satz geschrieben hat jemand ein
paket für mich bitte an diesem satz
konnte ich direkt sehen dass diese
person vermutlich nicht muttersprachlich
deutsch spricht denn als muttersprachler
klingt dieser satz für mich ein bisschen
unfreundlich das mag jetzt vielleicht
für euch überraschen klingen denn ihr
lernt wahrscheinlich im
deutschunterricht das bitte einen satz
immer höflicher macht das stimmt auch in
den meisten fällen aber es gibt auch
einige fälle wo das nicht zutrifft
reden wir erst mal über die fälle wo
bitte einen satz höflicher macht das
kann man zum beispiel dann sehen wenn
man in einem geschäft ist und etwas
bestellt oder vielleicht in einem
restaurant etwas bestellt ein bier bitte
kommt sofort
lecker in dieser szene macht das bitte
den satz tatsächlich höflicher wenn ich
das bitte weglassen würde dann würde
dieser ganze satz fiel unfreundlicher
klingen ein bier
es heißt immer noch ein bier bitte ein
bier bitter da geht doch oder
wenn man also etwas bestellt dann macht
das bitte diesen satz tatsächlich
höflicher in anderen fällen ist das aber
nicht immer unbedingt der fall kannst du
bitte aussehen gitarre zu spielen das
ist zu laut und kannst du bitte etwas
freundlicher sein
das nervt könntest du vielleicht
aufhören gitarre zu spielen ich
telefoniere gerade und dass es etwas
laut natürlich mache ich hier nicht klar
was ist also der unterschied wieso ist
es höflich wenn ich im restaurant ein
bitte benutze wenn ich etwas bestelle
und gleichzeitig ist es unhöflich wenn
ich meinen mann um etwas bitten und
dabei bitte benutze der unterschied
liegt tatsächlich in der situation und
der unterschied liegt darin ob ich
meinem gesprächspartner die option lasse
ja oder nein zu sagen wenn ich in einem
restaurant wenn oder in einem geschäft
bin dann sind die rollen ziemlich klar
verteilt die eine person möchte etwas
haben sie möchte etwas kaufen
die andere person verkauft etwas wenn
ich also sage ein brot bitte oder ein
bier bitte dann formuliere ich
eigentlich keine frage sondern eine
aufforderung oder eine bestellung und
dieses bitte
macht die aufforderung höflicher aber
der satz ist trotzdem immer noch eine
aufforderung oder eine bestellung ein
bier bitte kommt sofort
wenn ich jedoch einen freund oder einen
nachbarn oder meinen partner um etwas
bitten dann möchte ich wahrscheinlich
eine frage formulieren und ich möchte
wahrscheinlich die option lassen ja oder
nein zu sagen
oder anders herum gesagt ich wenn ich
quasi mit dieser person so spreche wie
mit einem menschen in einem geschäft
dann klingt das so wie eine aufforderung
in der es keine option gibt ja oder nein
zu sagen wenn ich zum beispiel zu
janisch gehe und sage kannst du bitte
aufhören gitarre zu spielen dann klingt
das so als wäre ich in einem geschäft
und er müsste diesen service machen oder
das klingt so als würde ich mit einem
kind reden und habe die erfahrung dass
das kind auch tatsächlich das macht was
ich formuliere
wie kann man also im deutschen eine
bitte formulieren und gleichzeitig die
option geben ja oder nein zu sagen
hierfür gibt es in der deutschen sprache
zwei gute möglichkeiten
hey manuel könntest du mir zufällig
morgen beim umzug helfen
na klar mache ich gerne wann geht's los
die erste option ist die verwendung des
konjunktivs genaugenommen des konjunktiv
2 den konjunktiv 2 benutzt man im
deutschen immer um eine un- reale
situation zu beschreiben wenn ich den
konjunktiv zwei benutze signalisiere ich
also sprachlich schon dass das was ich
sage nur eine option darstellt ich
könnte zum beispiel sagen
könntest du mir helfen das ist also eine
sehr reale situation die ich mir gerade
ausdenke kannst du mir helfen ist eine
bitte eine direkte aufforderung könntest
du mir helfen ist gibt diese option ja
oder nein zu sagen vielleicht findet das
statt vielleicht nicht
hallo hey hast du vielleicht ein paket
für mich angenommen
ich glaube schon carina nicht dankeschön
die zweite option ist noch ein adverb
hinzuzunehmen ein adverb dass auch
signalisiert dass es eine option gibt
hier passen zum beispiel vielleicht oder
wohl könntest du mir vielleicht helfen
könntest du mir wohl helfen
das klingt im deutschen optimal höflich
und es klingt viel höflicher als wenn
ich sagen würde
kannst du mir bitte helfen fassen wir
noch mal zusammen
ihr könnt und sollte im deutschen gerne
das wort bitte benutzen
vor allem dann wenn ihr eine
aufforderung formuliert dann macht es
diese aufforderung höflicher in manchen
situationen ist diese bitte jedoch
vielleicht nicht genug um höflich zu
sein und in all diesen optionen oder in
all diesen situationen wo ihr eurem
gesprächspartner die option geben wollt
ja oder nein zu sagen
solltet ihr auf jeden fall den
konjunktiv zwei benutzen und auch
vielleicht das wort vielleicht um noch
höflicher zu klingen wenn man sagt
könntest du mir vielleicht helfen dann
klingt das auf jeden fall sehr höflich
wenn ihr lust habt dieses thema noch
weiter zu üben dann werdet doch ein
mitglied von easy german als mitglied
unterstützt wir unsere arbeit und
gleichzeitig unterstützt die auch euer
deutsch lernen dann bekommt ihr nämlich
zu diesem video und zu allen anderen
videos transkripte vokabel listen und
interaktive übungen
danke fürs zuschauen und bis bald
[Musik]